so right in the middle of care here it's
philosophical fragments there's this
short just really a matter of pages
short passage called the paradox and the
offended consciousness and he calls this
an appendix kind of a funny place to
have an appendix usually there at the
end of a work this one's right smack dab
in the middle and a little bit later on
after another chapter he'll have an
interlude where he says you know we're
putting something in between chapters
four and five so if you're Garrett is
playing around with this he's having
this be the appendix to chapter three
and in chapter three as we saw in the
third video in this sequence there's
this entire development on the part of
Reason which is trying to come to know
when we talk about reason we mean the
rational human being the rational human
being is trying to come to know the
universe to know themselves to know
their relations with other people to
understand you know what transcends them
where they fit into the scheme of things
and the reason runs into something
that's absolutely different from itself
and kicker Garrett calls this the
unknown he calls us God he calls this
later on towards the end the paradox and
it's something that that like he says
reason desires to to not only understand
itself but but it desires its own
downfall reason he has a passion that
it's motivated by and its passion is to
get beyond itself so what can reason do
with that or what can the rational human
being with that they can only do that by
by finding something that's that's
larger than themselves something that
can't be assimilated and broken down and
put into its boxes and classified and
then mastered by reason and that is the
unthinkable and that tend that ends up
being being God or the paradox so the
the fundamental question is is reason
going to grow or is reason going to just
sort of admit defeat or is reason going
to spin itself aloft into all sorts of
things that look like reason but aren't
really that rational so that's what's
going on as sort of the trailer gist and
he calls this an acoustic illusion what
is an acoustic illusion well I'll think
about throwing your voice I you know
with this I can't really do it because
you hear me talking at you and I don't
have one of those fancy cameras that
would you know split things into
different channels or anything like that
well you know we're listening to the TV
sometimes and we'll hear something and
it's in surround sound and the surround
so now these TVs is so good these days
that you know the TV is right here and
it sounds like it the you know whatever
it is is coming from over there and so
I'm thinking you know there's somebody
coming up the steps or what does that
sound that I'm hearing over in that
direction that seems to be a little
distracting turns out that's part of the
program ventriloquist's throwing their
voice
that's an acoustical illusion you could
have certain types of architecture where
if you stand in the right place you can
hear just as if they're standing next to
you something that somebody else is
saying way over on the other side of the
room there's there's some buildings that
are designed with that sort of thing in
mind so there's an acoustic illusion
going on here and we're going to spell
out precisely what that is but first he
says there's there's two possibilities
for the paradox and reason if the
paradox and the reason come together at
a mutual understanding so the question
is of understanding and a mutual
understanding of their unlike Ness
something in which they respect their
difference from each other so the
paradox understands reason reason
understand
the paradox they both understand each
they both understand themselves and they
understand their relationship and the
they grasp their fundamental difference
from each other not a problem for the
paradox because remember the paradoxes
after all God it could be a problem for
reason rational human beings
particularly the work
the reason is developed sometimes become
you know almost obstinate or stupid in
the process in there they're so bright
and they're so good at spinning out all
these webs of deductions and inferences
and implications and and you look at
them and you're like yeah but you forgot
this they're like wow that doesn't fit
into the system so I'm not going to
worry about that well you know if the
goal of reason is just to neatly
classify things or a master nature or
some of these other ideas you know help
us live together in society well if
that's it then okay the reason can be
content with that
but if reason is this it has a passion a
desire built within it to know to
understand reality to assimilate truth
to itself in itself to truth then reason
is inevitably going to collide with some
things that that you know pose it with
something like a foreign body within its
own substance that that it has to figure
out what am I going to do with this and
that's what we're talking about here in
terms of mutual understanding you can
understand the difference between you
and something else you can respect that
that difference without having to try to
automatically overcome it to break it
down to denigrate it to in the process
misunderstand it and Cara's going to
talk about some people who actually did
have that before and he says if they
come together in a mutual understanding
of their own likeness their encounter
will be happy like loves understanding
happy in the passion to which we have
not yet
name so it's not just the passion that
is driving reason to its own downfall
that we're concerned with there's also
another passion that Kierkegaard is
going to talk about in this this book
and also to give this away for you even
that passion is faith but we're going to
talk about that a little bit more later
on so if they reason in the paradox come
together in a good understanding of
their unlike this to each other then
they exist in this happy passion called
faith
if the encounter is not in understanding
the relationship becomes unhappy and
this unhappy love of the reason if I may
so call it and he says which it should
be noted as analogous only to that
particular form of unhappy love which
has its root in misunderstood self-love
no further stretching of the analogy as
possible may be characterized more
specifically as offense
so when reason and the paradox do not
come together in mutual understanding of
their differences which is not a problem
beyond the paradox aside the paradox is
perfectly willing to to do that it's a
question of whether reason the rational
human being or II I mean you can even
think about this brought more broadly or
you can think about this particular
design say this in terms of a group an
organization of society a movement of
thought if reason doesn't come together
in in mutual understanding then it is
going to end up becoming the offended
consciousness as he says it's going to
take offense and that's what this this
chapter is about so he says all offense
what we say about it is in its deepest
root passive in this respect it is like
that form of unhappy love to which we've
just alluded even when such a self-love
analysis itself in deeds of audacious
daring and astounding achievements it is
passive and wounded it's not entirely
whole as a matter of fact if you're
thinking about this in epistemological
terms in terms of knowledge in terms of
understanding in terms of thinking
reason is in taking offense in being
offended it is expressing a wound within
itself that we don't normally think
about we normally think about
rationality as something that's you know
pure higher than everything else
unassailable if you know it as opposed
to the emotions is you know not damaged
but Kierkegaard is getting at something
none of us are fully rational we're not
even sure you know a lot of the times
when we stress just how much were you
know separating reason from the passions
or the emotions or stuff like that you
know we can't be completely sure that
we're actually doing that but there
isn't you know some sort of passion
driving the reason in that case making
it is as you know human perspective a
slave of the passion we make all sorts
of crazy deductions and inferences on
the basis of insufficient evidence you
know taking positions that we don't
really have a full right to take being
obstinate when we're presented with with
any sort of evidence that might change
us in our mind to the contrary not being
willing to make the effort to understand
positions that seem opposed to our own
see whether they in fact are even
opposed or whether the problem is on our
side so you know reason is in fact
finding itself to be wounded and like
you says it's the pain of this wound
that gives it this illusory strength
expressing itself in what looks like
self activity
no offense like Kierkegaard says is an
act on the part of reason it is an act
on the part of the rational human being
in relation to the paradox in relation
to God so there is an active side to it
but it's fundamentally passive in that
it's not really calling the shots it's
not determining the parameters of you
know the possibilities here and it takes
it stand on the basis of sort of you
know one or two things either I'm going
to choose this and you're not going to
make me choose something else because
I'm going to choose it so I will or I
can't possibly see things otherwise
necessity compels me to see things this
way so you know something that that
presents itself as if its reason but a
reason you might say in Chains and both
of these are sort of secretly tied in
with with each other anyway let's go on
with this he says even when it tramples
on the object of affection even when it
painfully schools itself into a Hearton
indifference and tortures itself to show
this indifference even then even when an
abandonment itself to a frivolous
triumph over its success he's talking
about the unhappy love even that it's
passive such is also the case with the
offended consciousness would ever be its
mode of expression even when it exultant
ly celebrates the triumph of its
unspiritual 'ti it is always passive
whether the offended individual sits
brokenhearted staring almost like a
beggar at the paradox saying I can't
possibly make sense of this this is not
something comprehensible so that would
be the standing like the beggar
paralyzed by his suffering or Ishi's
himself in the armor of his derision
look at those stupid religious people
believing in all sorts of nonce
since you know what they think that God
you know changes his mind in history or
God would you know need to come and
redeem us or you know pick the sort of
things that people make fun of religious
people for saying and believing that's
sheathing oneself in the armor of
derision those Kierkegaard says and it's
interesting cuz you think about it it's
like going on the attack I'm gonna
demolish those those pretensions that
the religious people or their God would
have but really what it's doing is sort
of setting up an armor for oneself I
don't want to let that get into me so
I'm not going to do it I'm going to just
you know push it away he's still passive
in this case whether a fence came and
robbed the offended individual of his
last bit of comfort and joy or made him
strong the offended consciousness is
nevertheless passive it is wrestled with
the stronger and it shows strength is
like the peculiar agility induced in the
bodily sphere by a broken bag beautiful
metaphor of a very ugly idea reason has
a capacity to deform itself to make
itself lesser than it want to be in
relation to things that transcend it so
that it can keep itself to itself and
just hold on to what it what it has
that's what he was talking about there
and he says we can't distinguish between
an active and a passive form of the
offended consciousness if we take care
to remember two things one is the
passive form is so far activists to not
permit itself wholly to be annihilated
for offense like he says is always an
act so the person who is totally passive
with this is not allowing themselves to
to be sort of effaced by this they're
still there and they're still choosing
the active form is always so weak it
cannot free itself from the cross to
which it is nailed or tear the arrow out
from us woman so the you know when it is
active when it's pushing away the
paradox it's still in some respect
tormented
and I have to say you know on a personal
note I am reminded in this of the the
vast difference that I have myself
experienced in talking with a lot of
people involved in you know the study of
religions in religious life and
spirituality
I find that apologetic cysts on both
sides you know for religion and against
religion tend not to be particularly
happy people and by apologetics açaí
mean those who think that they're going
to find knock down drag down arguments
that are going to convince everybody and
they throw them in your face and they're
like see see look at this and some
religious people do that and some anti
religious people do that I don't even
say like non-religious people because
those people go beyond they become anti
religious and it's like you know their
own particular passion becomes showing
everybody how wrong they are well that's
that's you know that's what he's talking
about here by offense and that's that's
a particularly active form of it but it
still can't tear itself away so you've
watched those people and you're like man
you know if you don't believe in God
that's one thing but you certainly spend
for it for a god you don't believe in
you spend an awful lot of time thinking
about how much you you dislike him and
you're sort of expending your energies
on something that you say is nothing
well Kierkegaard would say that makes
perfect sense there you have a rational
person whose reason exists in an unhappy
lack of understanding in relation to the
to the the paradox he has a passion that
still nevertheless driving on towards it
and is unhappy in that passion so let's
go on from this so he says and this is
another really important point because
offense is passive the discovery if it
be allowable to speak thus does not
derive from the reason but the paradox
and here we're getting to this
of the acoustic illusion this is a
really important point and I want to
take the time to sort of separate this
out from from another point so he's
saying that the discovery of the paradox
and offense is not coming from the side
of reason
although reason thinks that it is it's
actually coming from the paradox he's
also going to say very soon that it's
not just the the discovery of it the
very fact of it like he says the the
understanding of it the existence of
offense is coming from the paradox as
well so that's something pretty
important if reason is really like
functioning on all of its capacity as if
it's you know running on all cylinders
as we say then it wouldn't actually stay
in offense not for long and I would
realize that its offense is actually
sort of a reaction on its part from what
is coming to it from the paradox what
reason is not you know that that that
well put together that that integrated
and so even to fully understand what's
going on with the fence that has to come
from the paradox why this is an acoustic
illusion and Kierkegaard just you know
talking in terms of voices is because
reason thinks that it's hearing its own
voice saying what's actually coming from
the paradise so the paradox is providing
the knowledge the understanding even the
term
of the problem reason is not able to
hear that coming from the paradox and he
has to sort of think this is coming from
me so it's like somebody and you know
people like this some people take credit
for everybody else's ideas and a lot of
times those people you know sometimes
they're very just you know deceptive and
opportunistic and they say yeah I like
that person's idea I'm going to take it
and they know that it's coming from the
other person and they don't convince
themselves that they came up with it
themselves and so they they're you know
gonna stay away from that person because
they know hey I screwed them over
there's a lot of other cases where you
know you're talking with somebody and
you've got a good idea and you mention
it they're like yeah yeah that's that's
a great idea
and then later on you hear them talking
about it and they're talking about it as
if it is their own idea and they're
convinced and they convince other people
because of this this is one of the
problems in dealing with with people who
are particularly bad off when it comes
to the you know self-deception
they can actually be convincing because
they think that they came up with that
idea themselves that it's their own
brainchild or something like that well
that's what's going on here with the
paradox and the the offended
consciousness so he says the paradox
itself he's got this very nice phrase
that's coming to us from ancient
philosophy it's a Latin phrase but it's
actually coming from an idea that that's
older and Greek philosophy there there
are some things that are supposed to be
indexed soui at falsie so the truth is
the index or the
the judge or indication or however you
want to put it of itself and of the
false so truth has a certain priority
over falsehood
likewise in at least in tradition
traditional Christian thought good has a
priority over evil
so that evil is really a prime a Schnoor
a corruption or something you know
missing or something going wrong with
the the good good has a priority over
evil it's not that they're just simply
opposites
same thing with truth of truth and
falsity well it's the same thing with
the paradox
he says the paradox is index at you dex
Suey and fall see the index and the
judge of itself and of what is false
what is false at least insofar as it's
not really getting things right is
reason it's certainly not getting it
right that it thinks that it's coming up
with all this on its own it's also not
getting things right in that it's you
know saying yeah I don't I don't think
that this stuff actually exists or you
know if it does it's a terrible terrible
thing it's absurd it's irrational I
can't possibly be in a good relationship
with it so like you says offense is the
mistaken recommence with which the
paradox repels and thrusts aside the
offended individual does not speak from
his own resources but borrows those of
the paradox just as one who mimics or
parodies another does not invent but
merely copies perversely beautiful way
to put it let me go back over that one
more time
she says offense is the mistaken
reckoning the invalid consequence and
what does he mean there what he means is
that reason is getting things wrong in
its own activity mistaken reckoning the
invalid consequence with which the
paradox repelled
and thrust aside the offended individual
does not speak from his own resources
again reason thinks the offended
individual thinks that they're on their
own that God or you know the divinity or
whatever you want to say the
transcendent sort of is just out there
by itself and not connected to it and
it's going to speak from its own
resources about it it's going to use its
own reasoning to figure out whether it
could be or could not be and it borrows
those resources from the paradox so this
is a kind of interesting because if you
think about this and I'm going to come
back to the rest of the statement of the
woman we're looking at you know
arguments for the existence of God
yeah chapter three and Kierkegaard said
you know most of the time they're not
actually doing what they're supposed to
do Kierkegaard's not a big proponent of
arguments for God's existence he says
you can't actually go from ideas or
attributes to existence you have to go
from something that actually exists and
then start talking about whether you
know it has these attributes or is this
kind of thing and he criticized what we
would see is the traditional theistic
proofs of God's existence Kierkegaard
would also be just as big of a critic at
least of this character guard of
arguments for the non-existence of God
of the sort of traditional types for
instance the argument from evil this is
this is a big argument that is given to
to try to claim that God can't possibly
exist and that's certainly not a good
guide not the God of you know
traditional Christianity Judaism Islam
not a God would be all-powerful all good
all-knowing
and yet have evil in the world well
Kierkegaard would say when you're doing
that when you're reasoning like that you
think that you're only using your own
resources and now you've sort of
disproven the existence of this thing
out there but really where did you get
all these ideas from in the first place
from that very thing whose existence you
are now trying to disprove and I think
he would say that about many of the
other arguments against God's existence
that you can find philosophers making
whether they're just reductive things
you know God can't possibly exist
because we know that God is just a
projection of our imagination our
fantasy of father figures you know from
our infantile dream or fantasy life you
know Olive Freud God can't possibly
exist because he's just a projection of
society writ large or something like
that sociological explanation any of
these sort of things reason thinks that
it has the upper hand and it's like you
know going to judge this really though
the trouble is that the arguments
against God's existence don't work any
better according to Kierkegaard than the
arguments for God's existence in part
because reason it isn't as capable as
you think it is and in part because
reason is deriving its powers from the
paradox now it goes a little bit further
this is where you know again this phrase
is very important it borrows those of
the paradox just as one who mimics or
parodies another does not invent that
Mary merely copies perversely so why is
he using that language their reason is
not fully rational human reason at least
when it takes the resources from the
paradox in straightening in them out it
somehow makes them in other ways more
crooked in restoring what it thinks to
be proper measure to them it distorts
the measure that would actually allow it
to make the right kind of measurements
and inferences you know we could go on
with these sort of metaphors it's
mimicking the paradox
it's parodying it it's taking resources
from it but then sort of you know
garbling them up and so he says the more
profound the passion with which the
offended consciousness expresses itself
the offended consciousness is expressive
you know screw God he's absurd I'm not
gonna have anything to do with any sort
of conception like that a God who could
allow infants to just suffer as a
terrible God with whom I want to and
have nothing to do you know all these
sorts of things or I haven't been
convinced you can't possibly convince me
because I know from my my own you know
experience that all there is is what we
see here you pick any sort of expression
of the offended consciousness that you
like even more subtle ones like you know
well okay there is a God but he's a
screw-up because he allowed the devil
and Adam and Eve to sin and then they
somehow screwed it up for everybody else
and that doesn't make any sense that's
an expression again of the offended
consciousness and his reason sort of
spinning its wheels and spitting its
venom at this object now like it says
offense was not discovered by the reason
far from it because then reason would
have been able to discover the paradox
but reason doesn't discover the paradox
instead what happens is reason is out
there kind of groping and the paradox
whack runs right into it says Here I am
you know that's a really good way to put
it because the paradox is not just you
know some sort of object that reason is
groping around and finally reaches and
now it's trying to find it it's a it's a
personal experience right
the paradox itself is in some ways like
a hyper reason its dynamic its
responsive so like it says no offense
comes into existence with the paradox it
comes and here you he reaffirms us it
comes into existence and now I think
that that's a passage that's well worth
reflecting on if we're thinking in terms
of existential philosophy Kierkegaard
said just we're looking at earlier stuff
that you know you're not going to prove
God's existence you start from something
being out there and then try to figure
out what the hell it is and what our
relationship is - and have we screwed up
our our understanding of it and you know
see what it would it actually has to say
those sorts of things but now he's going
a little bit further and he's saying
that offense comes into existence but
the offense is not something totally
distinguishable from the reason from the
human being he's talking about original
sin here without actually using the term
original sin he's giving a philosophical
interpretation to a theological
religious concept or maybe even
experience or if you like dogma the
offense comes into existence along with
us we don't create the effect
except insofar as we money it up even
more you know imagine that there's
there's water before you and it's
already a bit murky and in order to try
to make it less murky you you know try
to move the the silt away and now you
actually just drop the bottom even more
or you know there's a house of cards and
it's slightly leaning and so you say I'm
gonna I'm gonna fix this and now all of
a sudden they start coming down and
you're trying to rearrange that but it's
getting even worse and worse and worse
or imagine you know here's a culinary
metaphor they're the soup that you're
making isn't quite right there's
something missing to it so you add an
ingredient now there's too much of that
okay
oh how can i counterbalance this so it's
sweet I'll pour in something something
sour and now there's too much of that in
there and okay I'll add something bitter
to counterbalance that and pretty soon
it just tastes like you know some sort
of mishmash of all sorts of things well
that in a way these are all metaphors
that we can use to understand how we
make the offense worse but he says it
comes into existence here again we have
a moment this critical idea that
Kierkegaard has been stressing over and
over again the moment time matters
personal histories matter if all we had
was the sort of Socratic philosophical
understanding then the moment doesn't
matter in the moment is just absurdity
and folly as he says but if we have of
the capacity or if the the universe or
God or you know whatever we want to call
it
has the capacity to sort of rupture into
time to make some moments more decisive
more critical more important more
determine
not only of what comes after but also
what came before if that's the case then
we have to take that very seriously
so he says if we pause at the moment the
paradox is there for the moment is the
paradox in its most abbreviated form
because of the moment the learner is in
error and man who before possess
self-knowledge now becomes bewildered
with respect to himself instead of
self-knowledge he receives the
consciousness of sin and so forth from
the psychological point of view he says
the offended consciousness will display
a great variety of nuances within the
more active and more passive forms that
he says I'm not going to try to explore
those and and you know if you look at
Kierkegaard other works in essence what
he's doing is he's exploring many
different forms of this but like he says
all offense is a misunderstanding of the
moment since it is directed against the
paradox which again is the moment so
by taking offense the rational person is
you might say imposing categories on to
the paradox not that the paradox can't
accept or admit but which are just not
going to be applicable to it in such a
way as to yield for reason what it is
that reason really is desiring what it
has passion for something greater than
itself to be put into relationship with
that in a way reason is like the clumsy
lover who keeps again making things
worse
you know first they take offense and
there they're clumsy and somehow you
know screw things up with the the the
beloved and the beloved is like well you
know not the brightest guy but I still
love him I'll still be in a relationship
with them but he feels so guilty about
it that now he's like self-conscious and
he's trying to make things better and
each gesture that he makes because it's
it's ill-conceived makes things worse
that's the way their reason is like when
it's in a band relationship with the
paradox so like it says the reaction of
the offended consciousness is to assert
that the moment is folly and that the
paradox is folly so here we get to
another key term the absurd reason says
to the paradox says to the moment this
is absurd how can there possibly be
anything important as a French
intellectual said to French student said
to Maurice blown down when he was
studying at the colon I'm wrong this is
a french student in asserting in a
disparaging christianity how can
something that happened in some
backwater village of the roman empire
2,000 years ago have anything to do with
me let alone with philosophy let alone
with the world today let alone with
reality as a whole and
Nelson that was sort of perfectly
representative of the attitude of his
time during the French Third Republic
and that would be sort of a rejection of
the moment you could also say this about
more more personal moments you know a
person suddenly realizes or perhaps
gradually realizes wow I've been
radically wrong when it came to
understanding matters of spirituality
and religion what the hell am I gonna do
now
figure out how to get myself back on
track but I have no idea how to get
myself back on track I just know that I
don't like where I am now I'm kind of
ashamed of how things have gone and
there's less and less time available to
me to figure out you know the big
questions in life and as it turned out
the way in which I was doing about
trying to figure them out was they
actually screwing me up even more and
making me less able to hear the answers
that are out there and you know they
start spinning their wheels and then
something happens and they say oh yeah
God did this I I felt a sense of peace I
knew that I had to start looking at
things this way and that didn't come
from me well you know from again from
the perspective of the offended
consciousness you look at that sort of
stuff and you're like wow you're a
religious nut yeah okay you you may
think that God came in and did something
in your being and changed you in some
sort of way but that's got nothing to do
with me Jack and nor should I have
anything to do with anybody else
that's absurd the very you know paradox
itself is for reasons point of view
absurd and so he says the offended
consciousness holds a loop from the
paradox and the reason is quia absurdum
because it is absurd but it was not the
reason that made this discovery on the
contrary it was the paradox that made
this
and now receives the testimony from the
offended consciousness again the
acoustic illusion reason thinks that
it's saying this for the first time and
then the paradox says in return I'd been
saying this to you all along
finally it heard me great you still kind
of got it wrong but at least now you
finally heard some of what I was saying
to you
and so the reason says the paradox is
absurd but this is mere mimicry because
the paradox is the paradox because it is
absurd the offended consciousness holds
a loop from the paradox and keeps to the
probable since the paradox is the most
improbable of things but again it's not
reason that made this discovery it
merely snatches the words Kierkegaard
says from the mouth of the paradox
strange as this may seem for the paradox
itself says and now notice again the
paradox is being framed in a very
personal way so that it has you might
say equal equal rights of personality
with with reason it's there the
relationship that reason would have with
it is not a subject with an object but
of the subject with another subject so
the paradox says comedies and romances
and lies must needs probable but why
should I be probable the offended
consciousness holds aloof from the
paradox and what wonder since the
paradox is the miracle
again this discovery was not made by the
reason since it was the paradox that
placed the reason on the stool of
wonderment and now replies why are you
so astonished it's precisely as you say
the only wonder is that you regard it as
an objection when the reason boast of
its splendor is in comparison with the
paradox which is most wretched and
despised and also came from the paradox
and now you know a lot of this makes
more sense if you actually frame it as I
think that you have to do in terms of
actual you know scriptural texts
so Kierkegaard has in mind again what
he's doing here is he's giving you a
philosophical interpretation of
religious doctrines of theological
conceptions that are coming from the
paradox having revealed itself for him
in the person of Jesus Christ and where
would we get our conception of this from
these religious texts which we call the
Gospels and you know if you actually
read the Gospels this is sort of a
digression but I think this is actually
really good to keep in mind at this
point again let me stress this
Kierkegaard is giving a philosophical
interpretation of religious doctrine and
so if that religious doctrine is coming
from the Gospels if you read these
things there but wildering there is no
one single consistent message and
anybody who tells you that the Gospels
are all just about this phrase or this
phrase with this idea no they're they're
paradoxical you know you read through
them and you're like wow that's a hard
saying there's actually like a whole
genre of things that are called hard
sayings that come up in the Gospels
Chesterton after Kierkegaard of course
points out that those who you know like
to compare the historical Jesus who
probably was this this you know a really
mild meek guy with the Jesus of the
church you know who was this mean
repellent person who's all about rules
and and thou shalt nots and stuff like
that he says man they've never actually
read the Gospels have they because if
you actually read the Gospels you'll see
that in a lot of cases what you're
getting from religious authorities is
kind of watered-down milksop kind of
stuff that if you actually read these
texts this guy is you know like he says
speaking with authority and saying
things that people were just bewildered
by only whoa hell are you saying here
well that would be what Karen's calling
the paradigm
so again I'm gonna say this phrase one
more time than hopefully I won't bring
it up again
philosophical interpretation of a
theological idea and now notice the
philosophical interpretation would be on
this side right because what is
philosophies main tool reason the
theological truth is coming from here
towards reason the reason is
interpreting it's back to this because
they're still a little bit more than we
have to to say in them this is actually
turning out to be a much longer video
than I expected he has a couple little
digs here about about philosophers that
are really good and he says when reason
takes pity on the paradox and wishes to
help it to an explanation now this is
what happens when German idealist
philosophy approaches religion or in
other different rationalistic views of
philosophy are sort of superimposed not
just on religion as a social thing but
on the objects of religion you know the
philosopher is gonna make God speak more
clearly I'd be a way to put it
he says when reason takes pity on the
paradox that wishes to help it to an
explanation
the paradox does not indeed acquiesce
but nevertheless finds a quite natural
that reason should do this for why do we
have our philosophers if not to make
supernatural things trivial and
commonplace when the reason says it
cannot get the paradox into it's had
what the reason takes offense and says
that doesn't make sense
the paradox says it was not the reason
that made the discovery but the paradox
which is so paradoxical is to declare
the reason a blockhead and a dunce
capable at the most of saying yes and no
to the same thing which is not good
divinity and so always if you're just
saying this is something this is a
dynamic which you're going to see over
and over and over again
running throughout the history of
religion the attempts from of the human
being to place itself in relation to the
paradox that is to God to the divine
that which transcends it that which has
given it this very problematic that
which gives it in some respect what it
needs to get past its offense that it's
taking when the human being says I know
better than God how God should talk hey
God should be that setting things up
according to Kierkegaard for you know
the paradox would just say wow you you
really managed to get that wrong now
after this in this this this section
here Kierkegaard has another one of
these these passages where he has the
the writer being accused of plagiarism
and this is a particularly important one
he's done this now three times he says I
hear someone say it's really becoming
tiresome of the way you go on for now we
have the same story over again now what
are the expressions you've put into the
move off of the paradox belongs to you
and character God says yeah that makes
perfect sense you know why cuz I'm over
here the paradox would have given me
this just as much as it would have given
you no reason in the abstract that so he
says why should they belong to me when
they belong to the paradox
now his interlocutor says back to him
you can spare us your sophist tree you
know very well what I mean these
expressions are not yours
nor by you put into the mouth of the
paradox but are familiar quotations and
everybody knows who everybody knows who
their authors are so this this imaginary
critic is saying you know you're not
plagiarism a rising from the paradox
you're plagiarizing from other human
beings who have said these kind of
themselves so this is a really important
point a lot of people will say
Kierkegaard is you know all about the
lone individual no sense of community no
sense of tradition continuity here's a
place where Kierkegaard is actually
stressing something like a community of
inquiry a tradition of placing oneself
in relation to the paradox so he says my
friend your accusation does not grieve
me but what you say makes me exceedingly
glad for I must admit I could not
repress a shudder when I wrote them down
I scarcely recognize myself that I who
am usually so timid and apprehensive
dared to say such things but if the
expressions are not by me perhaps you'll
say who they belong to
now that is that is great it actually
makes me glad to read that to say it to
you I said this in in my classes and I
say this in some of my videos one of the
best parts about about teaching
philosophy is I don't have to make this
stuff up it's already there somebody
else has already said it I just have to
like you know do my part in bringing it
to to contemporary life but I don't I
don't invent what Plato said Plato said
what Plato said and Plato figured that
out on his own 23 and then Samad change
a hundred years ago and I get to
actually follow in those footsteps and I
have to admit that I myself am one of
these kind of people who would be you
know timid and apprehensive to say such
such things I mean I'm going to say that
there is a paradox there that reason has
a passion for that automatically you
know or necessarily leads it into
collision with with this paradox and
that you know reason takes offence at it
you think I would have come up with that
on my own
I wouldn't and Kierkegaard says he
didn't either I'm often struck when I'm
reading through great philosophers yeah
what they I'm struck by what they say
and I'm I'm pleased that it's as if the
whole range has been set out in front of
me things that I never would have gotten
around to thinking myself wouldn't have
the capacity to to come up with on my
own
and I'm like wow so somebody could
actually think that that's that's great
the same thing when I read great
literature history's the you know the
wisdom literature of the world religious
texts the the breadth and the richness
and the depth of what's available is
kind of shocking
so anyway Kierkegaard says okay so I
didn't say these things who set up Who
am I plagiarized from and the critic
says nothing is easier the first is by
Tara tholian the second by haben the
third by haben the fourth is by
locked-on seus and frequently quoted the
fifth is by Shakespeare and a comedy
called all's well that ends well
and he actually like you know quotes
seen and hacked the six is by Luther and
the seventh is a remark by King Lear
well you know these are not bad people
to be in company with certo Leah one of
the great thinkers of the early church
true you know he there were some things
a bit off about the guy but you can say
the same thing I'm most of the church
fathers if you dig deep enough you know
look at your roaming is kind of a
cantankerous guy but he translated the
Bible until it's a Latin and delusional
Walgett and with some great letters so
it's here tolya Tertullian said that
stuff wow that's that's that's great
locked on seus another one of the great
Church Fathers a Christian philosopher
who wrote a defense
the Christian philosophy haben a fairly
obscure these days German philosopher
who sort of opposed to what was going on
in German idealism Shakespeare there's a
lot of great thinking that I wouldn't
hesitate to call philosophy embedded in
Shakespeare's plays Martin Luther Martin
Luther was not a dummy you know he he
didn't get to be the the the sort of
head of a movement by just you know
coming up with one idea and just
sticking with that some of his followers
are kind of along those lines but if you
actually read Luther you may not agree
with them I myself don't agree with him
on a lot of stuff including his choice
of language sometimes but you have to
admire the the brilliance with which he
actually works so he says you see I'm
well informed that I've caught you with
the goods this is imaginary interlocutor
and Kierkegaard says yes I perceive it
but now will you tell me whether all
these men have not spoken of their
relationship between some paradox and an
offended consciousness and will you now
note that the individuals who spoke were
not themselves offended so you remember
going back to the question does he
understand at the very beginning of this
this entire section the paradox the
offended consciousness we said if the
paradox and the reason come together in
a mutual understanding of their unlike
this the encounter will be happy like
loves understanding happy in the passion
to which we have not yet assigned a name
and now we can assign that name now we
can actually put some of this stuff in
so I'm going to clear some of this
ground a little bit the happy
understanding the name for that passion
is faith and there are other people who
have been in this relationship of faith
with the paradise with God for
Kierkegaard faith is not simply a set of
propositions that you have it's not
turning your brain off and saying okay
you know don't think anymore just feel
just accept these things that you don't
understand faith is the work by the
rational human being through this
passion through this drive to make sense
of the paradox which gives itself to
reason which gives reason resources to
make sense of it which reveals its very
condition to reason so that reason
doesn't have to stumble around in the
dark by itself trying to reconstruct the
entire universe the human condition and
God all on its own out of its own you
know ideas or experiences so Kierkegaard
says the individuals who spoke with us
we're not themselves offended but
precisely persons who held to the
paradox and yet they speak as if they
were offended that's why they're so hard
to understand sometimes an offense
cannot find a more characteristic
expression for itself is it not strange
that the paradox should thus as it were
taking the bread from the mouths of the
offended consciousness reducing it to
the practice of an idle and unprofitable
art and he says one merit unquestionably
belongs to the offended consciousness in
that it brings out the unlike miss
between reason and the paradox more
clearly for in that happy passion which
we have not yet given a name the unlike
is on good terms with the reason there
must be a difference if there's to be a
synthesis in some third
entity but here the difference consisted
in the fact here this is where we're
gonna leave off it was very important
the difference consisted in the fact
that the reason yielded itself
well the paradox the stowed itself and
the understanding is consummated in that
happy passion which will doubtless soon
find a name and this is the smallest
part of the matter finding a name for if
even if my happiness does not have a
name what I'm happy I ask for no more so
reason like you said yielded itself does
that mean that reason disappeared that
you know what we're talking about here
is a total lapse into irrationality no
reason yielded itself that is an act
that is a choice on the part of the
rational human being also a response to
a person on the other side a person who
gives itself to reason the person who
gives reason even an understanding of
what it is to be over here and the
relationship is taking place between
them this is a very beautiful
metaphysical passage and that's what
we're going to leave off and spent a lot
of time a lot more than I intended to
talking about this very short passage
but like we found out there's an awful
lot there and now we can plow ahead
through the rest of philosophical
fragments